alright so the last game for this brief
session I am not sure what I scored in
this four games or three games before I
think not much one out of three or
something maybe I really shouldn't play
with it's a 30 degrees here or in my
room I mean not fahrenheit but Celsius
and this is damn hot all right so I'm
the Rue La Paz exchange when Queen d6
Queen f6 just a recently popular line
and he immediately went for the Queen
exchange which shouldn't travel black so
much can quite a castle long rookie age
so um no no big deal here okay so he
tries to prevent this yeah I think I
could even play but should be seven it's
no big deal but don't want to give up
the bishop pair so early I mean a move
like it should be seven the sort of
young allows black to play only for a
draw
and it's okay this kind of opening it's
not really suited to to win when a lot
with black but you can you can try at
least okay so he actually would allow me
to to demolish the pawns here I think
I'll do that just to get some imbalance
going here I want to put points on c5
and b6 so that is some Bishop assume
somewhat limited and I have a point of
attack also the seat upon situ or maybe
a 2 also so now let's cap cover d5 first
so how to continue here should I play
Bishop 8th form sort of tying down a
rook to to this I'm like now let's try
this I mean I don't have any any big
problems if I'm just yes sort of passing
don't do much because why doesn't really
have a good plan here
yeah you can do can do all those kind of
things but don't think it leads to much
i could try to get an ID to see form I'm
not so sure what it is doing on c4 it's
very nicely positioned I mean that it
looks nice but the Schneider doesn't
attack anything okay please chief form
okay so let's um try a firm this night
can do anything good here so should I go
there immediately or well maybe I can
try this g 6 a-5 kind of maneuver this
worked in a in a game like like two
games before and in this session
actually work very nicely to be the
Grand Master so to see for now right not
completely sold on this it looks nice
but not so sure what the nidus is doing
ok maybe consider term this really to be
a threat night a three-year taking this
maybe maybe it was so
g6 f5 cannot open up the position ok
let's try to get rid of the night
and then f 5 m-f five he could go in I
to d5 but does it does it really bring
much ok I want to try to complicate this
a bit here cannot go see 5 and if he
takes on f5 I can take here and take C 2
also now g5 I can vr1 not sure play
rookie six
maybe can I can kick and go back now
have neither form okay interesting what
is the idea don't don't get it really
take here
97 maybe night is 700 d 7 mm maybe not
sure so let's recap sure here first so
it takes now Bishop takes yeah I'm a
porn up but he's got those ideas so go
in the seventh
so
so just take here yeah okay take and
what now rook air-five the young on rook
g7 I'm hmm I see Bishop f form on rook
g7 I'll I was thought of rook age 53
free body has got Rooker Bishop f4
attacking c7 with both the rock end okay
he wants to exchange really I mean I'm
upon up but he's got the f porn and
still hard to believe to be honest
honest upon I mean be five before and so
on that's a double porn but it's upon
ok so maybe here preventing kingi form
and attending king d5
the king of porn and cam i think is
really winning the points are important
the extra porn
I think I'm threatening c4 c5 now see
for its for check c5 and night f5 this
kind of stuff but I also can can simply
advance first what
some people are really really funny I
mean I can I can never lose this I mean
on time or blundering a night or
something but why should I take a draw
ok so it's the king and porn and
game-winning I actually think so but
okay I'm not one hundred percent sure
maybe this was very stupid but I still
have have those kind of moves to improve
the position it shouldn't shouldn't
spoil anything
alright so my to be six now and just
grabbing a form
King a3 I can just take
yeah so it paid off to to not exchange
into the king and porn end game the
sauce was really simpler
yeah okay I'm so difficult really
difficult position I shouldn't I
shouldn't be worse or anything here but
he's sort of transposed into this end
game and here only yeah here only black
can win I mean maybe it is flat-out
winning and I'm also I don't understand
it also just drooped g7 here he would
have played roop g7 is this so terrible
yeah computer gives me just a minimum
advantage have a porn or something Luke
g7 white confide I mean yes the bishop
which is potentially a good piece right
now it's not doing much but I don't see
why you should should exchange rooks
here cause rupture on g7 is just nice
maybe it was afraid of rook aged 5 and
didn't really see Bishop f4 this is me
as possible yeah all right I think
pretty interesting game thanks thanks
for watching and talk to you soon for
new games